اللي قدامكم ده هو سكوت تومسون رجل اعمال
امريكي والرئيس التنفيذي السابق لعده
شركات مرموقه معظمنا عارفها زي باي بال
وياهو احنا دلوقتي في اواخر 2007 اوائل
2008 لما سكوت كان الرئيس التنفيذي لباي
بال ومدير قسم التقنيه السابق فيها وبيال
وقتها كانت شركه فرعيه مملوكه بالكامل
لمنصه التجاره والمزادات الالكترونيه
الشهيره جدا ايب باي اللي كانت قيمتها
السوقيه وقت القصه دي 18 مليار دول وشغال
فيها 16000 موظف حول العالم باي بال
وايباي عموما كان عندهم يا اخوانا فريق من
اقوى فرق مكافحه الاحتيال في العالم وقتها
في 2000 موظف منهم 50 حامل للدكتوراه في
هندسه الحواسيب بمختلف تخصصاتها طبعا زي
ما كلنا عارفين في الفتره دي الشركات
العالميه كانت لسه
بتستكتر شبكه الانترنت حديثه النشاه
وعلشان كده كان من اهم اولويات شركات دفع
وتحويل الاموال والتجاره الالكترونيه هي
مكافحه محاولات الاحتيال المالي
الالكتروني سكوت في الوقت ده وصل له طلب
وتوصيه عاجله من شركه راس المال المخاطر
بنش مار كابيتال علشان يقابل حد اسرائيلي
اسمه شفات شكيت شفات ده كان مجند سابق في
جيش الاحتلال وكان مسس شركه صغيره فيها 50
موظف اسمها علوم الاحتيال فرود ساينس في
تل ابيب عاصمه الكيان المحتل والشركه دي
اللي اسسها شفات مع شريكه رائد الاعمال
الشهير سار ويلف كانت معنيه بمكافحه
عمليات الاحتيال واكتشاف اصحابها قبل ما
تكمل بالنسبه لسكوت المقابله دي كانت
مفروضه عليه لان بنش مارك كانت من اهم
واقدم مستثمري ايباي وفي نفس الوقت بنش
مارك كانت مهتمه بالاستثمار في الشركه
بتاعه شفات وسار دي المهم قعد شفات قدام
سكوت وسالوا سكوت ها ايه الجديد اللي تقدر
تقدمه لنا في مجال اكتشاف المحتلين فرد
عليه شفات وقال له احنا عندنا فكره بسيطه
كده كده ان العالم مقسوم لطيبين واشرار
والتركيه هنا او الخدعه علشان نكافح
الاحتيال اننا نفرق ونعرف دول من دول طبعا
دي اجابه زي كده لما اقول لحد منكم بيدرس
في الجامعه مثلا علشان تنجح لازم تذاكر
ايوه يعني ايه الجديد فاسكت ساعتها كان
محبط من الاجابه وبدا يفكر ان الاجتماع ده
فعلا تضيع وقت بس قال هكمل شويه وبدا يسال
شفات عن طريقه شغل الشركه وعدد العمليات
اللي ارزو واكتشفوا كانكم محتال وهكذا
وعلشان يطلع من الاجتماع بطريقه شيك قال
لي شفات انا حدي لكم 100000 عمليه من بي
بال علشان تجربوا عليها طرقكم في تتبع
الاثار الرقميه وعاوزكم تحللوا العمليات
دي وترجعوا لي بالمحتل اللي فيها من عدمه
و هنخبط بيانات شخصيه من كل عمليه علشان
التابعات القانونيه والخصوصيه وكده طبعا
ده صعب مهمه شركه شفات ده اكت خاصه وان
العمليات دي سبق وفرزها باي بال بالفعل
وعارف نتائجها يعني الشركه عارفه مين
المحتلين وايه هي عمليات الدفع والتحويل
السليمه والاهم ان شركه علوم الاحتيال
اخدت خمس سنين من وقت نشاتها علشان تراجع
40,000 عمليه بس علشان كده سكوت اعتقد انه
هيشوف شفات بعد 10 سنين ثانيين ولا حاجه
عبال ما شركته تخلص كم العمليات المهول ده
بس ما كانش متوقع المفاجاه المذهله اللي
هتحصل بعد ثلاث ايام بس سكوت دخل على
ايميله ولقى رساله من شفات انهم خلصوا فرز
العمليات ولما سكوت ادى النتائج لفريق باي
بال علشان يطبقوها مع نتائج الشركه
الاسرائيليه الناشئه اخذوا اسبوع ولقوا ان
النتائج بتاعه شركه علوم الاحتيال ادق
واسرع من نتائجهم وطلعوها في نص مده
المراجعه وبامكانيات محدوده جدا مقارنه
بامكانيات باي بال نفسها طبعا سكوت كان
هيتجنن من اللي حصل وعرف ان ايباي لازم
تشتري الشركه الاسرائيليه دي باي ثمن وفي
اسرع وقت ممكن قبل ما تقنيتها تقع في ايد
المنافسين وبالفعل في اسابيع معدوده
وتحديدا في اواخر يناير 2008 اشترت ايباي
شركه علوم الاحتيال بمبلغ 169 مليون دولار
في واحده من اكبر عمليات الاستحواذ على
شركه اسرائيليه وقتها القصه دي هي واحده
من القصص المعروفه عن قطاع التقنيه
الاسرائيلي الفائق اهم قطاع انتاج للكيان
المحتل واللي مدي له سمعه عالميه ضخمه جدا
والقص الصه دي وغيرها اتذكرت في اشهر
كتابه عن القطاع ده وعنوانه امه الشركات
الناشئه لمؤلفيه دانس نور وشاول سانجر اهو
القطاع ده بيواجه ازمه عنيفه بدات من
نهايات 2022 وزادت جدا بعد عمليه طوفان
الاقصى اللي شنتها المقاومه الفلسطينيه
على مستوطنات غلاف غزه في اكتوبر اللي فات
2023 في الحلقه السريعه الخفيفه دي اللي
لازم تشوفوها للاخر هنبص على قطاع التقنيه
ده في اخر كام سنه واهميته بالنسبه
لاقتصاد الاحتلال والازمه اللي بتواجهه
وهل هيخرج منها ولا لا يلا بينا انا اشرف
ابراهيم المخبل
الاقتصادي الذكاء الاصطناعي واحد من اهم
المجالات والتخصصات المطلوبه في سوق العمل
الفتره دي وبقى ليه استخدامات كتير في كل
حاجه تقريبا زي انشاء المحتوى وبناء
المواقع والتجاره الالكترونيه وغيرها
علشان كده عايز اشكر اكاديميه حاسوب على
رعايتها الحلقه دي وانهم نزلوا دوره جديده
شامله لتعلم الذكاء الاصطناعي الدوره
عباره عن 43 ساعه فيديو هتقدر تتعلم فيهم
باسلوب عملي وشيق الخوارزميات والمفاهيم
البرمجيه وراء تحليل البيانات وتمثيلها
مرئيا وتعلم الاله والتعلم العميق وغيرها
وهتكون تجربتك التعليميه مركزه على ممارسه
اللي بتتعلم على مشاريع حقيقيه بتستخدم في
سوق العمل اللي بياه لك للمنافسه بقوه في
المجال ده اكاديميه حاسوب بتقدم دورات في
معظم مجالات البرمجه وتطوير التطبيقات
وبيبدا معاك من الصفر لغايه الاحتراف وفي
تطبيق عملي على اللي بتتعلم وتقدر بسهوله
تقدم بعدها على شغل من خلال مواقعهم بتاعه
العمل الحر زي خمسات و مستقل وقدرنا ناخد
منهم كوبون خصم ب 100 دولار على اي كورس
عندهم لمتابعي المخبر الاقتصادي لاول 20
شخص هيشترك استخدموا كوبون الخصم اللي
ظاهر قدامكم على الشاشه ده وهتلاقوه برده
تحت الفيديو في تعليقات فيسبوك لو بصينا
على ال 30 سنه اللي فاتوا هنلاقي ان
التكنولوجيا الفائقه الاسرائيليه كانت وما
زالت محرك نمو مهم جدا لاقتصاد الاحتلال
والكلام ده بدا من منتصف الثمانينات
تقريبا لما كانت دوله الاحتلال لسه
بتتعافى من ازمات اقتصاديه متتاليه ومرورا
بنضج القطاع ده في التسعينات وثوره انتل
اللي حصلت مع استثمارات الشركه الامريكيه
في
1999 و2000 وصولا للمرحله الحاليه علشان
نتخيل الصور لازم نعرف ان الكيان المحتل
هو موطن لاحد اكبر قطاعات التكنولوجيا في
العالم وقطاع التقنيه الاسرائيلي هو
القطاع الاكثر انتاجيه عندهم وبيوصف حوالي
12% من القوى العامله وبيمثل حوالي 18% من
الناتج المحلي الاجمالي ونص صادرات البلاد
في 2022 وفقا لبيانات هيئه الابتكار
الاسرائيليه اللي هي الوكاله الحكوميه
اللي بتدعم تنميه القطاع ده في السنين
القليله اللي فاتت كان وما زال في محاولات
رهيبه من نخبه الاحتلال الاقتصاديه
والسياسيه وحكوماته نفسها انهم يعزلوا
قطاع التكنولوجيا الفائقه وغيرها القطاعات
اللي بتتميز بها دول العالم الاول الحديثه
عن فكره الاحتلال ومنظومته يعني بالبلدي
كده احنا في اسرائيل امه الشركات الناشئه
حاجه والاحتلال وقمع الفلسطينيين وقتلهم
وحروبه معاهم دي حاجه ثانيه ما لناش دعوه
بيه كانك بتتعامل مع دولتين بالضبط
الملاحظه الذكيه دي هي ملاحظه حظ الدكتور
عساف اورون باحث الاحصاء الاسرائيلي
المقيم في امريكا والمناهض للاحتلال
للاراضي الفلسطينيه واللي بيقول ان ده كان
وما زال علشان المستثمرين من كل مكان في
العالم يستمروا في الاستثمار في شركات
الكيان المحتل من غير ما تواجههم اسئله
صعبه واحتجاجات واضرار من حاملي الاسهم
والجماهير المستهلكه لمنتجاتهم وهكذا
والجهد ده في عزل قطاع التقنيه الاسرائيلي
عن دمويه الكيان المحتل نقدر نرجعه لشخص
واحد بس هو نفتالي بينت مليونير
التكنولوجيا الفائقه ورئيس وزراء الكيان
المحتل سابقا قبل ما يرجع لنا السفاح
نتنياهو حاليا لكن المحاولات دي نهارت
طبعا مع اول قلم خدته اسرائيل لما حصل
طوفان الاقصى طب ليه لان معظم العاملين في
قطاع التقنيه ببساطه هم من مجندي جيش
الاحتلال وطول ما شنت المقاومه هجومها
اعلنت حكومه الاحتلال الحرب واستدعت
360,000 جندي احتياط منهم عشرات الالاف من
عمال التكنولوجيا الاسرائيليين وده كان
معناه ان قطاع التكنولوجيا بيواجه نقص
كبير جدا في عملته في الاشهر الاخيره دي
وده كان ملح زياده على جروح اقتصاد
الاحتلال اللي تقلص بنسبه 2% في اخر ثلاث
شهور من السنه اللي فاتت 2023 حسب بيانات
بنك الاحتلال المركزي واللي توقع ان الحرب
المجرمه والمجنونه اللي بيشن الاحتلال على
اهلنا في غزه هتكلف اقتصاده حوالي 8 50
مليار دولار الحرب تسببت في زياده توتر
عدد كبير من مستثمرين الاجانب اللي فلوسهم
بتمثل عصب قطاع التقنيه الاسرائيل الاهم
والتوتر ده كان بدئ معاهم من اوائل السنه
اللي فاتت لما حكومه الاحتلال بقياده
بنيامين نتنياهو اطلقت خططها للاصلاح
القضائي وعلى راسها محاوله تقليص صلاحيات
المحكمه العليا الاسرائيليه لما ده حصل
خرجت مئات الالاف مظاهرات احتجاجيه في تله
ابيب على مدار شهور طبعا ده مناخ ما ينفعش
خالص مع المستثمرين الاجانب واي مستثمرين
الحقيقه في اي مكان على وجه الارض اللي
بيبقوا عاوزين جو مستقر وقوانين واضحه
وتسهيلات حكوميه واستقرار سياسي وعسكري
علشان يضخ فلوسهم بمختلف الاشكال علشان
كده في الوقت ده وحسب تقرير مطول لاذاعه
امريكا الوطنيه العامه ان بي ار في عدد من
مستثمرين قالوا لبعض اصحاب الشركات
الاسرائيليين ان ده وقت انشاء شركاتهم
خارج الاراضي المحتله لانك ببساطه لو ما
عندكش نظام قضائي مستقل عن الحكومات
والكيانات السياسيه فانت اكيد محتاج تاسس
شركتك بره وبالفعل من اوائل السنه اللي
فاتت 2023 وفي عدد من رواد الاعمال
والمستثمرين الاسرائيليين بيبحثوا نقل
شركاتهم لدول زي البانيا واليونان وقبرص
وبيشترى عقارات باعداد كبيره في البرتغال
مشروع الاصلاحات ده واللي هو طبعا من بنات
افكار حكومه السفاح نتنياهو اللي هي اكثر
حكومه يمنيه متطرفه شافها الكيان المحتل
منذ نشاته تسبب في ان قطاع التكنولوجيا
الاسرائيلي الفائق ولاول مره من 20 سنه
تقريبا ما اطلقت غير 400 شركه جديده بس
وهو اللي كان متعود على اطلاق من 1300 ل
1400 شركه كل سنه وعلشان تستوعبوا رقم 400
ده فخلونا نعرف ان ده كان عدد الشركات
الجديده اللي بيطلقها القطاع في اوائل
الالفينات علشان كده السنه اللي فاتت كلها
بتتوصف بانها اسوا انكماش شافته صناعات
التكنولوجيا الاسرائيليه من نشئته ولحد
اللحظه اسوا حتى من انكماشها في اوائل
الالفينات ساعه ازمه انهيار فقاعه
الانترنت او دوت كوم واسوا من فتره 2008 ل
2009 ودي الفتره اللي بدات فيها الازمه
الماليه العالميه في 2008 ثم اعتداء
الكيان المحتل على قطاع غزه في اواخر نفس
السنه واوائل 2009 ولو بصينا هنلاقي انه
السنه اللي فاتت شركات اسرائيل التقنيه
الناشئه جمعت 6 مليار دولار مقارنه ب 16
مليار دولار في 2022 الارقام الصعبه دي
للقطاع التقنيه بدات من اول ما وزير العدل
الصهيوني ريف ليفين فتح بقه واعلن عن خطه
الاصلاح القضائي في اوائل يناير اللي فات
2023 بهدف تقليص صلاحيات منظومه القضاء
الاسرائيليه وبالتالي حمايه نتنياهو من
محاكمته بتهم الفساد وتلق الرشاوى وساعتها
ما كانش حال العالم يسر يعني كان عندنا
انكماش لصناعات التكنولوجيا العالميه
عموما بسبب ارتفاع التضخم واسعار الفايده
وتراجع سوق الاسهم فجت الاصلاحات المقترحه
دي ومعاها مظاهرات الاحتجاج الضخمه جدا
علشان تبوظ الدنيا اكثر للقطاع الاسرائيلي
الاهم وبعدها جه هجوم طوفان الاقصى علشان
يكمل عليهم ويضرب كرسي في الكلوب ونلاقي
مكاتب معظم موظفين شركات الاحتلال التقنيه
فاضيه علشان تم استدعائهم للقتال في غزه
وحصل تباطؤ في تطوير المنتجات وحصل شبه
تجمد لتدفق الاموال هناك ورغم ان تكلفه
الحرب العاليه جدا على جيش الاحتلال
وحكومته والضرر الاقتصادي المتزايد اكبرهم
على تسريح عدد كبير من جنود الاحتياط
واعادتهم لوظائفهم مره ثانيه الا اننا
عندنا نقطتين هنا غايه في الاهميه تخلي
التسريح ده امر مشكوك في فعاليته على
الاقل لحد ما توضح الصوره اكتر النقطه
الاولى هي ان حكومه نتنياهو المنهار
سياسيا بتحرم باي طريقه وبتحاول تستفز حزب
الله اللبناني علشان تفتح جبهه حرب شامله
معاه والحزب زي ما معظمنا عارف قدراته
الصاروخيه اكبر من قدرات المقاومه
الفلسطينيه بمراحل وبالتالي احتمال كبير
تكلفه الصراع معاه تكون عاليه جدا عن
التكلفه الحاليه فلو الجبهه دي اتفتحت فده
معناه ان جنود الاحتياط واللي فيهم عشرات
الالاف من موظفي قطاع التقنيه زي ما وضحنا
هيرجعوا اماكنهم ثاني كانه ما فيش حاجه
حصلت والنقطه الثانيه متعلقه بان المقاومه
نجحت بال بالفعل في قتل عدد لا يستهان به
من جنود الاحتلال وده معناه بالضروره ان
قطاع التكنولوجيا الاسرائيلي هيع اني من
خساير بشريه لسه مش عارفين حجمها بالظبط
بسبب تعتيم جيش الاحتلال على بيانات
خسائره الحقيقيه وفي نقطه ثالثه متعلقه
بان عوامل التضخم وتباطؤ حركه الاستثمار
العالمي لسه موجوده ومتوقع تستمر في 224
او هيكون في انتعاش فاتر في افضل الاحوال
زي ما بيقول دي روزنبرج رئيس مكتب بلومبرج
السابق في الاراضي المحتله والمحرر
الاقتصادي بصحيفه هارتس الاسرائيليه
وبالنسبه لشركات اسرائيل التقنيه الناشئه
فهي محتاجه زي اي شركه رؤوس اموال لدفع
تكاليف البحث والتطوير وعلشان يلاقوا
طريقه يرجعوا بيه عوائد معقوله للمستثمرين
علشان يضخه اكتر وهكذا وبدون سوق مستقره
ومزدهر فده غالبا مش هيحصل وبالتالي
المستثمرين زي ما شفنا هيرجعوا خطوتين
ثلاثه لورا طب هنا هيط ططلع سؤال الحلقه
المهم جدا يعني يا اشرف القطاع هينهار من
ورا اللي بيحصل ده هنا هرد واقول اكيد لا
اولا معروف عن قطاع التكنولوجيا
الاسرائيلي انه قطاع مرن ومتعود على
المصايب دي وعلى الحروب ودمويه الكيان
المحتل المعتاده اللي بتخليه في حاله عدم
استقرار شبه متصله يعني حكومه الاحتلال
مثلا وفرت 100 مليون دولار مبدئيه لدعم
الشركات الناشئه المتعثره وفي اكثر من 70
مستثمر ومدير تنفيذي لشركات التكنولوجيه
امريكيه زاروا الاراضي المحتله اواخر
ديسمبر اللي فات علشان يدرسوا ضخ
استثمارات هناك وبالفعل في نفس الشهر جمعت
شركه سكيل اوبس ودي شركه اسرائيليه ناشئه
متخصصه في اداره الموارد السحابيه 21 وص
مليون دولار وجمعت شركه زيرو نتوركس
الناشئه للحمايه السيبرانيه 20 مليون
دولار وهكذا بل بالعكس في بعض المحللين
عندهم قناعات ان قطاع تكنولوجيا الكيان
المحتل بيتغذى على الا الضاع غير المستقره
والفترات العنيفه العسكريه والامنيه بسبب
ان نسبه لا باس بها من منتجات القطاع ده
هي اجهزه وانظمه وابتكارات تقنيه عسكريه
واستخباراتي وامنيه وده بيخلي الفترات دي
فترات ازدهار لشركات التكنولوجيا
الاسرائيليه والحقيقه الكلام ده مظبوط لكن
الى حد ما يعني اه الفترات دي بتكون مفيده
للشركات اللي بتشتغل في الاراضي المحتله
وفي الاسواق الدوليه وبتصعب بتصدر تقنيات
عسكريه وامنيه لكنها اكيد مش مفيده
للشركات اللي بتبت كر وبتطور تقنيات سلميه
مدنيه لكن في نفس الوقت المره دي برده مش
زي اي مره فاتت وعدد لا باس بهم
المستثمرين هيكونوا محتاجين قبل ما يرجعوا
يشوفوا وقف لاطلاق النار وحاله استقرار
مستمره ويشوفوا حل ناجع للي بيحصل في قطاع
التقنيه ده لا يتضمن تشكيل تهديدات امنيه
اكث على اعمالهم في الاراضي المحتله
وهيحافظ فه ما بتمد ايدها على منظومه
القضاء الاسرائيليه طبعا احنا هنا لازم
نركز على فكره العلاقات وان واحد من اهم
عناصر قوه وادي التقنيه الاسرائيلي هو
علاقاته بالمستثمرين في اوروبا وامريكا
تحديدا وده بيوفر علاجات سريعه حتى الاسوا
المشكلات لكن اكيد مهما كانت مرونه القطاع
ومهما كانت قوه علاقات رواد الاعمال
الاسرائيليين بالمستثمرين الاجانب فده مش
هينفع لحظه لو استمرت حكومه نتنياهو جيش
الاحتلال في وانهم الدموي على القطاع
وحربهم المفتوحه هناك وجرهم لشكل حزب الله
لان في النهايه الاستثمار ما بيعرفش غير
العائدات والفلوس ودول ما بيجوش غير من
استقرار واضح وبيئه متزنه انا مش هطول
عليكم اكتر من كده قطاع التقنيه
الاسرائيلي هو من القطاعات اللي ممكن اقعد
اتكلم معاكم فيها لحد بكره فلو عاوزين
حلقه ثانيه مفصله اكث عن نشاه القطاع ده
وقصته اهميه الاستثمار في التكنولوجيا
وايه اللي ممكن نتعلمه منه كدول عربيه
عرفوني في التعليقات ما تنسوش تشتركوا في
دوره الذكاء الاصطناعي من اكاديميه حاسوب
عشان تتعلم واحده من اهم مهارات المستقبل
وتاهل نفسك لفرص افضل في سوق العمل واخيرا
بفكركم باهميه التفاعل مع الفيديو كالعاده
علشان نتجاوز قيود منصات التواصل
الاجتماعي المستمره على اي محتوى مناهض
للاحتلال اشوفكم على خير
[موسيقى]
سلام
ا